welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast for today's episode we've got an
excellent interview Greg and I sat down
with Molly Galbraith and Marika Hart
from girls gone strong throughout the
interview we discussed a number of
female specific lifting topics so for
example we talked about pelvic health we
talked about lifting during pregnancy
lifting after pregnancy so if you are a
female lifter or if you coach female
lifters this is a really really
informative interview we want to thank
Molly and Marika for stopping by and
spending some time with us and we also
want to thank you for listening so as
always enjoy the episode we have a
number of really important topics to
discuss today but before we get into
that first of all thank you Molly and
Marika for joining us today
thanks so much for having us thank you
for having us now Greg and I have a lot
of things in common and one of the
things we have in common is that we are
both men and so we are very much open to
the possibility that we might have some
blind spots when it comes to female
specific topics and considerations for
lifting so to start things off I want to
begin with the topic of pelvic health so
Marika for female lifters or for people
who coach female lifters what do we need
to know about pelvic health oh that's a
big one okay so what probably we've
covered a lot in some of our smaller
courses and also within our bigger
certifications that goes on strong is
really trying to give people some of
those nuts and bolts when it comes to
pelvic health
and probably the first thing that we
want people to understand is to
understand scope of practice so knowing
what you can and can't work with that
diagnosis for a lot of fitness
professionals is outside of scope and
developing some of those relationships
with health professionals locally so
that you can refer to and get referrals
from and then the next step would be to
have a good screening process in place -
and I don't know is this something Eric
and Greg that you guys have been taught
to ask people about some of their pelvic
health concerns or do you have a
screening form not to put you on the
spot I'm just
curious to know whether this is
something I guess within teaching
programs currently that people are
learning for client intake we ask people
just generally are there any any like
health concerns that might really affect
anything related to how we would need to
do our job and so if someone has a
pelvic health concern that's when they
would bring it up but we don't ask like
targeted questions to say like you know
do you have any specific pelvic health
concerns just more do you have health
concerns generally yeah and then people
can choose whether to opt in that
information or not yeah
so interestingly I mean I know there was
a study that came out of Perth a few
years back where they actually just
asked women going to the gym like as
they came out did little survey how many
of you leaked when you cough sneeze jump
laugh which is what we call stress
urinary incontinence and it was 49
percent of regular gym goers who had
symptoms of stress urinary incontinence
so it's actually really prevalent we can
talk about prevalence in lots of
different sports and lifting and we can
get into that a little bit more later
but I think it's really important to
understand that it's actually symptoms
of pelvic floor dysfunction are really
really common and it's likely that
people coming to see you women coming to
see you for coaching of lifting are
likely you know you're gonna see some
people who have some symptoms so we
would really love to see more a
screening process happening more often
in gyms whereby you would ask some of
these questions and some of the things
we're really looking at would be the
stress urinary incontinence which we
just mentioned pelvic organ prolapse and
pelvic organ prolapse is basically when
you get descent of one or more of the
pelvic organs and we're talking about
the bladder the bowel and the uterus and
basically you lose some of that
myofascial integrity in the pelvis
that's holding everything in place and
those organs start to drift down towards
the entrance of the vagina and the way
that people will often describe that
will be a sensation of a heaviness a
lump a bulge a dragging feeling and it's
probably one of the biggest risk factors
for that is vaginal job
for Jonel childbirth but it can't happen
really at any stage in life and it's
actually they've done some studies
looking at some I think was paratroopers
this is awhile back and actually these
are women who've never been pregnant
never given birth and they had around
fifty percent of them had pelvic organ
prolapse anyway so it's quite prevalent
in some types of physical activities too
when does it become a problem it's a
problem when it becomes symptomatic so
if your clients are describing to you
this and I got this heaviness feeling
downstairs or I feel like a lump will
feel like something is coming out then
that's very likely to be pelvic organ
prolapse so that's that's quite common
in in the athletic population what are
the other things we'd probably look at
pelvic pain pelvic pain which probably
you've heard of things like
endometriosis or painful periods
statistically really really common and
we know endows around about 10% of the
population although it seems to take
about ten years to get a diagnosis these
days but yeah you'll probably see that
in a lot of your athletes as well or
painful periods and that's 7080 percent
of the population so these are all
things that we kind of cover within
pelvic health so anything to do with
leaking of feces or urine anything to do
with pelvic organ prolapse diastasis we
tend to cover in pelvic health as well
which is that abdominal muscle
separation that you get through
pregnancy and we can talk about recovery
from that a bit later
and um pelvic pain and I'd say they're
probably the the big ones that we we
cover a lot of in pelvic health that get
a bit of an overview for you definitely
yeah and some of those prevalence
numbers were absolutely shocking
I did not expect them to be that high
yeah I was actually gonna ask a couple
follow-ups about that
yup for the for the gym goers with
forty-nine percent rate of stress
urinary incontinence did that account
for whether they had previously been
pregnant or not like what what does that
prevalence look like no it was general
it was general population so they were
between like I think 20 and 60 years of
age someone who had kids some had not
gotcha
and then
or the the pelvic organ prolapse mm-hmm
do we know that that's you know roughly
like a 50% prevalence in the general
population like is there data on that or
is it mostly just because those women
were paratroopers and you know dealing
with more stress that could potentially
like stretch out ligaments and fashio
that's a great that's a great question
and look you can go crazy looking
looking through all the research on
pelvic organ prolapse and probably one
of the things that's changed in more
recent years is that we used to I say we
as a community in in pelvic health with
the gynecologist
used to believe that really there
shouldn't be much movement of the organs
so the way that we test it is we
actually do a vaginal examination and we
ask people to bear down and we have a
look and we see how much movement there
is of the anterior or posterior wall of
the vagina so we look for things that
are basically moving down and whether
they move out of the body as well and
that's obviously more significant
prolapse now in previous years anytime
there was movement especially as it
comes towards the entrance that would be
considered a diagnosis of prolapse and
then you take that box and you go into
that sort of category and we and we
grade that or we stage it in terms of
stage one two three and four with a
bigger number being worse basically now
what's happening is we're starting to go
we'll hang on is this supposed to not
move at all like maybe there supposed to
be some movement and maybe that's okay
so when you asked me about prevalence I
think prevalence is probably if you're
just talking about a structural
situation I think it's really high and I
wouldn't be surprised to find that 50%
or more of the population having it and
certainly if you've had if you've been
pregnant or you've given birth we're
gonna see really high numbers but then
we have to figure out what is normal
because we don't see people before they
get before they had a pregnant generally
mmm-hmm so we now probably have created
a situation where we have like with
lumber spine you know you go an MRI the
general population you're going to see
some discs voltar's right you're going
to see a little bit of wear and tear
how much is normal and how much like a
normal aging process
a normal physiological process and how
much is pathological so I think this
story this sort of I guess our thought
processes around prolapse are changing
and we're really now moving towards
thinking we'll look if it's all staying
internal and if the person doesn't have
any symptoms maybe that's okay maybe
that's not something that we need to
actually call prolapse maybe we should
just say look this that's a normal
variation gotcha that makes a lot of
sense because when when I hear prolapse
in any context my brain immediately goes
to a very bad place like that that's not
like a happy term when you hear like
some Organists prolapse it's like oh
[ __ ] something very very bad is
occurring sorry I think that what you
just said helps helps contextualize it a
lot so like in terms of what's the
difference between like general
prevalence versus like symptomatic or
problematic prevalence so of the women
dealing with pelvic organ prolapse how
often is that problematic for them and
then what can they do about it
great question the truth on that is we
don't know it seems to be that the more
significant the grade or stage of
prolapse is the more likely people are
to be symptomatic mm-hmm so certainly it
once it comes out of the body what we
call a stage three or four prolapse
those women are far more likely like I
don't know percentage-wise but you're
probably looking like 7080 percent maybe
more there will be strangely some people
who literally have part of their organ
outside of their body and who will be
blissfully unaware on the flip side of
that you'll have some women who have the
tiniest amount of movement who have
severe catastrophize ation stress
anxiety significant symptoms for sure
but it doesn't seem to match
anatomically what's going on so there's
so it's a really good question and I
don't know the answer to that I think
for those with very minor structural
prolapse you're gonna see a lot a lot of
people who are asymptomatic but with
those with the more progressive versions
you're going to see much higher rates
there's probably more that
sort of relationship well and one thing
too I just want to want to pipe up here
I know Marika has been doing an
incredible job but some some statistics
that I think will also blow your mind
are up to 19 percent of women will have
surgery for incontinence or pelvic organ
prolapse by the time they're 85 and 30%
of those women will have to have
multiple surgeries so for so many women
they've there's been a lot of shame
around this topic there's been a lot of
confusion there's been a lot of just not
understanding that either what they're
experiencing is not normal or that
they're something can be done about it
and so I think for a lot of women they
have these symptoms they're experiencing
these things they think it's normal or
they're too embarrassed to bring it up
especially with incontinence they think
it's normal with pelvic organ prolapse
they're often too embarrassed or scared
to bring it up and so they don't ever
get treatment for it and so like Marika
said you know it's um it there's yeah
there's just there are things that can
be done about it which is a really good
thing there are and there are a lot of
things that when we talk about scope of
practice you know Marika is a
physiotherapist I'm a strength and
conditioning coach I think a lot of
coaches and trainers think well I don't
really need to know this stuff because
it's outside of my scope of practice but
Marika actually gave an incredible talk
at a conference a couple years ago where
she had surveyed women in her community
about what things helped their symptoms
of prolapse and a number of them were
things that coaches and trainers could
actually coach their clients through and
as a coach or trainer again having that
relationship with your client and with
their physical therapist you need to
know about these types of topics even if
you're not obviously diagnosing and
treating it there is still a lot that
you can do as a health and fitness
professional and a lot that you need to
understand about what you were role is
so I'd love I want to get back to Marika
talking about what women can do about it
but I just wanted to pipe up and share
that so up to 19 percent of women will
have surgery for incontinence or pelvic
organ prolapse and up to 30% then will
have to have multiple surgeries which is
just like again you think it's something
if it happens to a really small
percentage of women and it's just not
true no yeah I mean that that
since and I'm I'm honestly blown away by
these prevalence numbers you're saying
like I would have never anticipated that
and I I like to think of myself as
someone who's like relatively
approachable and non-judgmental and I
know I'm trying to think I believe I
know more than five women and I've never
heard anyone talk about this so I I mean
pelvic organ prolapse like that's a new
that's a new term for me like that that
is the degree to which people don't talk
about it so yeah I think it's I think
it's awesome one that you're talking
about it generally and to that you have
these prevalence numbers just so if any
women are out here listening to this
they know that it's not something that's
like super weird and uncommon to
hopefully be stigmatize it to some
degree yeah I mean I'll tell you really
quickly I've been in health and fitness
room was 17 years I've coached women for
primarily my entire career as a strength
coach I owned a gym I've trained clients
online and in-person and it wasn't until
gosh 2014 when girls got strong had
released a strength and conditioning
program and someone had reached out to
us about using it with their wife who
was pregnant and I was like okay well
let me do some research about how maybe
I'm this night might need might need to
be modified slightly and I started
digging and I was like how in the world
have I been a coach for 10 years trained
under some of the smartest strength
coaches physical therapists PhDs and I
didn't know anything about this and
that's really what kind of kicked off
the crusade at girls gone strong to
start providing this this information to
people and to help open their eyes that
it's not a niche 85% of women in the US
will have a baby at some point in their
life and you know these these again
these numbers affect women who haven't
had children but again but talking about
you know pre and postnatal women as if
they're an inch is just like you know
ridiculous every number I've heard so
far has absolutely blown my mind eighty
five percent of women will have a child
wait now one blew your minds
yeah totally dude most people have kids
that's a lot that's a high number my
mind is completely blown ever every step
of the way I mean it's it's that's
comfortably below historical averages
well that's news to me
don't me to throw in suppose if you have
yeah III very much wants you to do this
because when Eric's mind is being blown
she makes very amusing faces and I'm
sitting right across from him so throw
as many as you can at him we can do a
little quiz if you like you can guess
the percentages of God leaked all right
let's go
volleyball uh-uh 60% oh very close 66%
yeah thanks endurance runners oh let's
go
54% 50 well done
triathletes um yeah I'd say 55 there's
actually lower is 37 which is
interesting it must be doing a little
bit of a lower impact stuff um
gymnastics
oh man this is tough because there's a
lot of impact but also they tend to skew
young I'll go on the high side let's go
70 yes spot-on
yeah I mean that that's very that's very
unfortunate for them but I'm proud of
myself
he's not happy for all the ladies
leaking all right
trampolining last one um 65 9000 holy
[ __ ] you know so our numbers weren't
that bad for our estimates but basically
what because you blew my mind with all
the numbers leading up to that I just my
filter was like yup Tim oh it was like
what number would you say double that
and then say it like these numbers are
absolutely astonishingly high now
throughout the convert this whole
conversation kind of started you know we
talked a little bit about trainers
strength and conditioning coaches having
some kind of screening process but you
know one of my follow-up questions that
I've been dying to get
- especially after hearing these numbers
is okay you implement this screening
process and you know if it's all nope
don't have any of that stuff
I think I know the answer what you do
with that you you move ahead but what do
you do when you implement the screening
process and you find out that some of
this stuff is present what is the next
step for the typical trainer or coach
who wants to make sure they're staying
within their their scope of practice so
first things first we we do include
these pointed questions within their
screening process what we've also
implemented relatively recently at girls
comes strong in terms of our like par
cues that we have people fill out is we
have essentially created a boundaries
section where we say hey there are a
number of topics that are going to
affect your overall health performance
you know progress your workouts you know
working with me as your coach you know
ideally we'd basically be able to have
conversations about these things that
there any of them that you don't feel
comfortable talking about you can check
this box below so essentially we give
people an opportunity to opt in or opt
out of conversations about certain areas
of health and fitness so it can be their
nutrition for some people for some women
that's a huge trigger that they aren't
interested in talking about their body
weight it can be their menstrual cycle
it can be pelvic floor health things
like that so we basically give them a
paragraph explaining like hey there are
a number of things that can affect the
way that I write your training program
and how I coach you and what your
results are opt into these conversations
that you're open to talking about and
then we put again more pointed questions
specifically about pelvic health and
pelvic health symptoms we highly highly
highly encourage that all health and
fitness professionals develop a referral
network with other professionals that
you trust who might be working with your
client so that's enemy at pelvic health
physical therapist a an OBGYN a
registered dietician you could even give
massage therapists of things like that
but having a if you work with women
having a relationship with a pelvic
health physical therapist is so so so
critical and the good news is is
again they can they can actually do an
internal examination or most well that's
it that's another tangent there are
pelvic health physical therapists in the
u.s. who do internal examinations and
some who don't
the term pelvic health physical
therapists is much less regulated here
in the United States whereas in
Australia you absolutely like you can't
call yourself a public health physio
unless you do internal examinations that
have done a significant amount of
schooling which marika could speak to if
we wanted to but having a relationship
with public health physical therapists
is so critical you have the conversation
with your client say hey what's you're
experiencing is really common the good
news is that there's you know treatment
for this you can work with a pelvic
health physical therapists generally it
just takes a couple of sessions and you
know where they get the get the
diagnosis they're given some exercises
to do they make some recommendations
about what they should or maybe should
not be doing in the gym give you some
ways to modify their exercises when
they're having symptoms and generally I
mean Rick it what would you say three to
five sessions max working with the
pelvic health physical therapists for
most women they're going to start seeing
significant improvements yeah I mean
obviously completely depends on what
they come in to say me for but for a lot
of the people are coming in for exercise
and maybe they've got a little bit of
leaking or some mild symptoms yeah I
won't say them very much and so again
there are a lot of things that people
can do so if a woman's doing a goblet
squat for example and she confides in
you that she's leaking a little bit
while she's doing the squat there are so
many different things that you can do to
help her you can reduce the weight you
can reduce the volume so if she was
doing maybe 10 reps or 12 reps you can
back it down to six or eight you can
change the position of the kettlebell so
she can do like an off set load
you could try even a dumbbell instead of
a kettlebell she could change her stance
a little bit she might slow the exercise
down she might change her breathing
strategy she might try exhaling on
exertion there are a number of things
that you can do that in that moment can
help her better manage the symptoms that
she's having without stopping the
exercise completely so and that's a lot
again if you
education that we do at girls got strong
is helping health and fitness
professionals screen their clients have
a referral network for who to send them
to have trusted professionals to work
with and then teach them how on the spot
they can modify their clients
programming if they're experiencing
symptoms then of course once you go
through a number of things if they're
not the symptoms aren't alleviated you
could switch showed ever and exercise or
something of that nature but yeah
there's just a lot that that coaches and
trainers can do that is within their
scope of practice that can help their
clients you know manage these symptoms
and just improve their confidence and
their self-efficacy so much of the
issues around pelvic health with the way
women view themselves and their bodies
you know we know how important language
is I'm Greg like you said earlier you're
like when I hear the word prolapse I
think something very very bad and then
marika you could find that with what
Marika said that for the last X number
of years they've been assessing women
and thinking just a little bit of
movement in the pelvic organs is
prolapse so you know changes the way
women view themselves their capabilities
what they think is possible for
themselves and their bodies it changes
for a lot of women again Marika can
speak to this they stopped moving
altogether because they're nervous or
scared so it's really critical for
health and fitness professionals to know
there's a lot that they can do in
conjunction with a pelvic health
physical therapists to help their
clients manage their symptoms and
actually treat pelvic organ prolapse and
incontinence the thing that's so
surprising to me is that it it sounds
pretty simple the way that you put it
it's really just a matter of asking your
client or you know doing some good
screening processes referring out to
some experts and then I mean like you
said in most cases just a handful of
visits with the right expert healthcare
professional and and we can see pretty
dramatic changes I mean that that's
pretty incredible it really is and part
of the issue is there's just so much
stigma around it like there are physical
therapists that I have had conversations
with here in the US that five years ago
didn't even know that pelvic health
physical therapy was an area of
specialty for pts
they had absolutely no idea and others
who did know but they snick heard about
it there was just like this again stigma
attached to it or they thought that
was weird there are some women who are
again afraid to maybe go there like a
physical therapist is gonna do what you
know like that's like you do that at the
OBGYN right but you don't think about
going to a physical therapist and having
an you know internal vaginal exam and so
I think there's again a lot of love
ignorant it's getting a lot better
thanks to folks like Marika thanks to
the work we're doing at GG s and other
awesome pelvic health professionals so
that it is getting it's getting a lot
better but the ignorance and then the
stigma and then the fear the lot of
women have around it and then just the
idea the shame and the idea that they
think it's normal
Marika can probably attest to this but
if you ask a woman do you leak when you
cough sneeze laugh or jump she's like oh
you know and you're like so you don't
leak it or no Julie cure and they say no
and you say even when you cough sneeze
laugh or jump and then she's like well
of course I do I've had two kids and
it's just considered normal it's
something that women think that they
have to live with because they have it
and all their friends have it and you
know I just have a weak bladder or this
is you know this is just the way that it
is because I've had two kids I was
actually just having a chat to Olympic
level athlete the other day and we were
in her particular sport which I won't I
won't say what it is but I was saying
you know do you know I'd really like to
talk to you in the team about public
health about incontinence about prolapse
and things like that is this something
that you think the girls might be
interested in and she laughed and she
said oh my god yeah half the team lakes
and so again like I know the stats and I
was still really surprised and and also
that sort of heard nonchalant kind of oh
yeah yeah well so-and-so leaks when she
I know when she changes direction on the
field and so-and-so leaks when she does
jumping like double unders in training
and things like this so interestingly in
some environments people I know did you
guys ever see the CrossFit video a few
years ago and they were talking about
leaking with CrossFit I did not I don't
either okay so it's on YouTube if you
want to look at it later but they it was
it was an interesting video because it
was almost glorifying going so
hod that you pay yourself that is so on
brand for CrossFit when they when they
sell t-shirts with like Uncle rhabdo the
clown like oh oh jeez of course that's
something they would do very there is a
t-shirt for paying yourself with a
double unders so I mean I guess that at
least Dee stigmatizes it to some degree
like maybe at least as being spoken
about I guess I guess but I I think we
want to change the message that yeah
it's common but you don't have to put up
with it and there are some things that
you can you can do to change that
when Molly talked a lot of she talked
about the referral network and one of
the things I would just encourage you to
do when you're reaching out to physios
is just to ask them how they feel about
lifters ask that question so what do you
feel about powerlifting what do you feel
about weightlifting because we as a I
can say this as a pelvic health physio
we as a group are ridiculously
conservative by nature and I think there
is a little bit of a culture of don't do
that that's gonna be too too heavy or
don't do that that's you know that might
cause issues and so you really want to
work with people who very much want to
support your patients got your your
clients goals so I would always ask that
question and say like if you're working
with a crossfitter for example just say
to the physio how do you feel about
cross fitting and if they say oh my god
it's the worst thing in the world that
that's probably not someone that you
want to develop a relationship with and
certainly with with things like
powerlifting and other forms of
weightlifting you know you just want to
make sure that they are on board to
support your patients your clients goals
just to make sure that you're all on the
same page we don't want to be having
that disconnect between the messages
know that that makes sense and and I
actually had a follow up about that
so when Molly was talking about scope of
practice and things that you can do with
a client in the gym on that day to to
lessen symptoms and decrease risk of
incontinence there in the session a lot
of those things sounded like basically
things to do
make the exercise a little bit easier
like reduce the weight reduce the reps a
little bit whatever so I was wondering
how some of that squared with say
training a female power lifter where if
they get stress urinary incontinence
when they're doing a max deadlift but a
max deadlift is is literally a third of
their sport how do you really square
that circle like if they go to a pelvic
health physio are they going to be able
to - generally like completely fix that
issue or will it just be kind of kind of
just a matter of trying to manage the
symptoms and and the lessen them to some
degree that will definitely be
individual if there is a week a pelvic
floor weakness then obviously some
strength training might help that it can
be little things like changing the
technique so when you talked you talked
about a threshold right you're wondering
like is this a tissue threshold problem
and every time they hit that they're
just gonna leak because they just can't
get that closure of the urethra there's
just so sometimes you know building up
the strength might help with that for
some people it literally is every time
they get to a like I'm thinking of a
client that US or a little while back
but you know she could chica deadlift
hundred and 70 kilos but every time she
hit 180 that was when she would leak so
for her yes we had to look at the pelvic
floor itself and and seeing whether she
had good pelvic floor strength whether
there's any prolapse but they were
looking at the technique side of things
because she was a sumo deadlift er and
every and which is a very wide stance
which is much harder on the pelvic floor
it's because it's in a more lengthened
position so it's actually changing the
stance can make a big difference
Molly talked about the breath side of
things so with things like incontinence
and prolapse is very much we often think
about the pressure system because you're
talking my inter abdominal pressure
right mm-hmm so to do a big lift we know
you need a valsalva like you got to have
a good breath hold and basically kind of
lock everything down we can't really do
an exhale on exertion when you're doing
a really really lift heavy lift it's
just I mean you guys are the experts in
that field but that's my understanding
you can but it's generally ill-advised
so so things like if someone has a
strategy where they're taking a really
big breath in before they close off
their glottis and do valsalva
you might get them just to exhale a
little bit maybe like 20 percent before
they do that and that might be enough
just to reduce that intra-abdominal
pressure a little bit
another thing might be looking at things
like belts and there was interestingly
there was a study on power lifters in
Australia and they're looking at
incontinence rates and then they asked
him I was about forty percent actually
if you want to know the stats for power
lifters and they asked them as well just
to offer some feedback on this topic and
if you ever mentioned that the they felt
that the brace was an issue at the belt
sorry the power lifting belt so also how
you use a belt can change things now one
of my colleagues Antony Lowe who
Molyneux's and he does a lot of work
with power lifters and CrossFitters he's
probably what are the few well I can't
say few people in this area because
there's probably a lot of people behind
the scenes doing good stuff but I spoke
to him quite a few times about about
using belts and one of the tips that he
finds works really well for the
incontinent side of things is actually
those people who use a strategy of
pushing through the belt like really
trying to push out with their abdomen he
gets them just to try and push to the
belt so get her make sure when they tie
it on when they actually lock it on that
there's still like a little bit of gap
that you put a finger in it but that
they sort of push out to the belt and
not try and basically push all the way
through and he says for some people that
works really well so there can be things
just within the strategy that may mean
that they can still go heavy but without
the symptoms and I like marika said I've
seen clients who have after public
health physical therapy have been able
to increase the amount of load that they
can lift before they start experiencing
symptoms and then other people who again
just hit a particular threshold and
experience leaking but the other thing
is and this is such a thing that's so
not talked about in this realm is that
for some women they don't really care if
they leak and so like you know I mean
they it is obviously a simple
bigger problem but a lot of people when
they're doing intense activities or
sports or they're competing in something
like they there are certain risks and
consequences that they are willing to
accept to be able to do the thing that
they love and so we talked about Marie
can I talk about this when we talk about
it with Antonia the guy that she was
just mentioning is that you know
explaining to your client like hey you
don't have to do this but ultimately
giving her the space and autonomy to
make that decision for herself because
there are some coaches who just want to
completely shut it down if she's
experiencing those symptoms but
ultimately we think again honoring you
know giving women autonomy and agency
over the decisions that they make about
their bodies and the consequences that
they're willing to accept letting them
know that they don't have to do that but
if they if they are and they want to
keep lifting like that's that's up to
them the other thing is like you know if
they're I don't know how often again
depending on like you you all program
for powerlifting significantly more than
I do I do a lot of stuff with general
population but you know there might be a
threshold at which she's starting to
leak and I don't know how much she could
work underneath say she was leaking at
ninety percent of her one rep max you
know programming a lot more of her
lifting you know beneath ninety percent
meet that threshold where she starts to
leak and only having her go over 90
percent
you know minimally as necessary leading
up to a meet could also be a strategy I
did have a quick follow-up I'm really
good at ignoring all of my problems even
when there are very serious problems so
I can totally relate to the idea of like
if you're a female lifter and you have
some leaking going on but you're just
like ah it's like fine like it's not
that big of a deal to me what would be
like are there serious medical
consequences to letting that go
completely unchecked and just lifting
through it and not trying to seek any
kind of remedy for that Hey
good question prolapse I'd say more so
you know when Molly was talking about
the stats
for surgery and the failure rates for
surgery they're really quite high
especially for anterior wall prolapse
posterior walls pretty good but you know
thirty percent recurrence rate so
sometimes so if you if women do push
through
to keep progressing their prolapse to
the point where because it's a bit
different with prolapse because you feel
it all you could feel it all day like
women tend to have a much lower
threshold for pushing through with
prolapse I find and you will find women
will self select away from things like
powerlifting if they have symptoms of
pelvic organ prolapse anyway so I'd say
prolapse you we probably worried more
about the progression there because if
it moves on surgery and then you have
failure rate and then post surgery they
might say we don't want you lifting any
more than 20 kilos which you can imagine
for a weight lifter is a joke with
incontinence if you keep pushing through
pushing through will it make it worse
maybe maybe not
it could reduce the amount of support on
the bladder neck which may mean they
leak more day to day but I don't think
we've actually got good data on that do
you know what's really interesting
though is that that that's study you
know talk about the forty percent in
power lifters when you actually follow
through they put a nice little flow
chart and I put on Instagram yesterday
because I just thought was really
interesting but they found it as many
women actually got better after starting
lifting has got worse in terms of their
incontinence so there were a lot of
women who are in content before they
started powerlifting but they found some
women actually got better so as they
generally got stronger their symptoms
improved so that's also something to
consider so for some people it doesn't
necessarily get worse they actually find
that as they train and maybe that's
something to do with them getting better
technique that are coaching who knows
there could be multiple factors we can't
really hypothesize too much on that but
there is always that chance - that some
people will get better so it's a bit of
an unknown okay that yeah that makes a
lot of sense so man we have so many
questions written down we have so much
to learn so I do want to move on to
another topic that I really am eager to
learn about pregnancy so your client
comes to you and says good news I'm
pregnant I would imagine the first thing
you say is congratulations but what
after that what are the current
guidelines when it comes to training
through pregnancy you know
first trimester to beyond well I got one
thing to say really quickly before I
think Marika can jump in on this but
actually the interesting thing about
what she said Eric about saying
congratulations is we typically
recommend and this might sound very
nuanced but we typically recommend
saying oh my gosh like in a somewhat
excited way like how are you feeling and
the reason is because so many women
depending on their situation like
pregnancy as it's a misconception that
it is always an incredibly exciting time
for women there are some women who are
terrified of being pregnant there are
women who didn't want to get pregnant
there are women who had trauma or PTSD
from their last birth there are women
who have lost children and are scared to
death of losing children again so I know
that seems like a little bit of a like
wow why are you know kind of like
perspective on it but I do and when you
say oh my gosh congratulations that's so
amazing
depending on your relationship with them
like you you might not be giving them
the space to feel like they can actually
tell you how they're feeling about it
whether that's terrified scared whatever
so when someone says you know I well
generally you can kind of tell on their
face right they're like I have something
to tell you I'm pregnant or they're like
I need to tell you something right right
so you can often tell but my responses
to her like oh my gosh how are you
feeling and it's still a very like you
know kind of upbeat like perspective but
how are you feeling really gives them
the space to hopefully be feel like they
can be a little bit more honest rather
than like congratulations that's amazing
so that's one little thing that I wanted
to pipe up and say really quickly before
Marika jumps in and she might have even
forgotten your question cuz now I've
kind of forgotten your question so yeah
the question was you know you learned
that your client is now pregnant and as
the coach where do you go from there
you know early in the pregnancy and then
progressing throughout the pregnancy how
does that affect our programming and
training decisions so one of the things
that's probably really important to
mention is that we'll get to screeding
in a second but depending on where Pia
are in the world and I'm sure your
listener group is pretty pretty well
spread but there are different
regulations and so one of the things
that we really encourage goes on strong
is that coaches and trainers reach out
to their regulatory body if there is one
because it can be a bit of a what's a
term you use a little bit it's like oh
yeah there's a while west yes that's it
Molly did say it's sometimes a bit like
the wild wild west in in fitness and
health and fitness but we really
encourage people to reach out to whoever
they're sort of certified with and say
hey look am I am I qualified to look
after pregnant women is there anything I
need to anything extra that I need to do
check with your insurance body to to
make sure you're covered to look after
pregnant women because in some cases it
may be that you need a little bit of
extra training for that so we just
encourage people to make sure that they
have the knowledge base that I'd let the
bare minimum because it's usually very
very very minimum in most training
regulation training bodies so make sure
you've at least got that and that you're
legally covered to look after women and
then the next thing we want to do is
make sure there's a screening process in
place and legally that is something that
if you're looking after pregnant women
you should do so there is a pregnancy
Park you form that you can send your
client in advance ideally and get them
to fill it in and get their doctor to
sign it off to make sure that they're
safe to exercise so with pregnancy the
probably the key thing really is to make
sure that we're really looking after the
safety of the mother and the baby and
this is from the start
right so when they're signed off by
their doctor it's making sure that
there's no contraindications it can be
tricky in the first trimester cause
sometimes I haven't really seen a doctor
or they may not know so that that's
where it becomes a little bit grey but
certainly moving on once they're sort of
in that healthcare team we've got to
make sure that they're safe to exercise
and there's a whole lot of if you want
to go into the if you want to like a
summary list of the contraindications
and precautions and things like that
the Canadian guidelines that were put
out 2019 I think are really really good
they're very comprehensive and I think I
would encourage your listeners just to
go and have a look at that because that
will give them an idea of you know who
are the people that I shouldn't be
seeing and it's it's pretty
self-explanatory you know but
just think from a safety perspective
that that's a really a really good idea
to start from there okay so moving on so
do you want to talk mostly about lifting
side of things yeah I would say so
so first things first you know the
pendulum has swung a bit when it comes
to women and strength training during
pregnancy so for a long time it was a
lot of folks recommended like all
pregnant women you know they're pretty
fragile they need to walk and maybe do
yoga and light stretching and that
pendulum is swung all the way over to
like they can compete in powerlifting
and CrossFit and you know they can do
whatever they want and you know women
pregnant women are strong and so we like
to say pregnant women are neither
fragile nor bulletproof they are strong
and resilient a combination of strength
training and cardiovascular exercise is
recommended in pregnancy 150 minutes per
week is I believe the minimum
recommendation and that's supposed to be
spread out over at least three days a
week and there are two really prevalent
myths when it comes to women and
strength training during pregnancy and
the first is that if you were not
exercising prior to pregnancy you
shouldn't start because you shouldn't
start anything new and the other is that
you could keep doing whatever you were
doing prior to pregnancy so first one
will tackle the first one you shouldn't
start anything new in pregnancy that's
actually not true as long as you are
cleared by your doctor for exercise and
like Marika said you don't have any
absolute or relative contraindications
it is fine to start exercising both
strength training and doing
cardiovascular exercise during pregnancy
but the caveat is that if you are
sedentary or didn't exercise prior to
pregnancy that you should not exercise
above like a moderate intensity so like
a 6 or 7 out of 10 on a perceived effort
scale and that goes for both strength
training and cardiovascular exercise and
then the idea that you can keep doing
whatever you were doing prior to
pregnancy is also not exactly accurate
number one hit high intensity interval
training is contraindicated during
pregnancy so that would be I'm sure most
of your listeners are familiar with what
hit is but essentially during the work
periods of hit you are working at a nine
point five to ten out of ten on a
perceived effort scale so your Center
pushing yourself to the absolute max
that is not recommended however if you
were exercising vigorously prior to
pregnancy
you can still exercise vigorously in
pregnancy and that's defined as about a
seven to eight and a half out of ten on
a perceived effort scale but as you get
more pregnant you will probably feel
like you are working harder doing less
so you know what you are doing to
achieve that like perceived effort might
be different but if you as long as you
stay in that range there there were
previously recommendations about women
not letting that heart rate get over 140
beats per minute and as far as I know
they found that rate of perceived
exertion or perceived effort is a more
accurate indicator of what's safe during
pregnancy and also you want to make sure
that your client is well hydrated
and that she's not overheating both of
those things are very important and then
during first trimester a lot of women
are going to experience morning sickness
which a lot of them say is all-day
sickness nausea exhaustion so a lot of
women find in their first trimester
maybe they're less motivated to work out
they're not really feeling it there
again dealing with a lot of exhaustion
dealing with some emotional overwhelm of
finding out that they're pregnant but
for the most part in the first trimester
and Marica you can hop in if you have
anything else to say about this but for
the most part in the first trimester if
they are feeling okay as long as they
are staying hydrated they're not
overheating and they're you know
listening quote-unquote listening to
their body in terms of their nausea and
exhaustion levels and things they can do
for the most part what they were doing
prior to pregnancy with the exception of
high-intensity interval training so for
for both of those contexts either people
starting new exercise or continuing what
they were doing before
it sounded like both of the the types of
things that would be contraindicated
would be intensity getting too high why
is that particularly problematic and
contraindicated for pregnant women
probably one of the difficulties we have
with research and pregnancy is there's a
lot of ethical concerns so we don't
stick women on a you know vo2 max test
and just basically crush them to see
what
and say it the same way they'd say we've
them lifting really heavy too we don't
have a lot of data on that but what what
they have found in studies and elite
athletes is that once people get past
about sort of 90 percent vo2 max there
does seem to be a reduction in blood
flow to the to the baby and it's
probably transient it seems to be
transient and it's it might be okay but
they just don't know so that's why the
recommendations are to sit around that
sort of generally speaking 12 to 14 on
the board scale so women can if they're
pretty fit they can work at a more
vigorous a vigorous level and that seems
to be okay but certainly if people want
to be working at that really high level
they should be doing it under the care
of the healthcare team and be really
closely monitored so that's certainly
with your elite athletes that's that's
the ideal they'll be working really
closely probably with exercise
physiologists and the obstetricians as
well as the physiotherapists is a bit of
a team I just want to make a note on the
the ratings of perceived exertion along
with that we use that general for the
general population and it seems to be a
really useful measure but in terms of
correlation between our PE and heart
rate in pregnancy the our PE does
underestimate the heart rate by about 15
to 20 beats per minute something like
that so weirdin if you're working at a
moderate intensity absolutely fine and
it's the easiest and that's what we use
all the time but if someone is working
at a higher level our PE becomes less
accurate and that's when we would
recommend people probably to use a heart
rate monitor as well and probably you
know and is is so individual of course
but you know stick around sort of that
up to 160 kind of thing is probably
about right but yeah just most of us are
working with the general population so
RP is fine yeah and that's why we also
use the reading out at like 1 to 10
instead of the Borg scale because that
general population is like wait at 12 to
14 you know it's 20
you know like that's so weird so I don't
know why don't we just say 6 to 7 out of
10 so we have kind of translated that to
be more relevant to general population
gotcha one one other thing I've heard
that I don't know if there's a
truth to this or not but one of the
things I've heard is that for a long
time resistance training wasn't
recommended to pregnant women one of the
reasons being that due to elevations in
relaxin especially during the last
trimester that joint instability would
be a problem and you try to train
somewhat heavy and all of your joints
explode is there is there any truth to
that or like just a kernel of truth or
you know do pregnant women need to be
concerned about heavy resistance
training for like relaxin related
reasons I lost a little bit of audio
there did you say something about joints
exploding yeah I was I was being
hyperbolic yeah relaxin that's an
interesting topic isn't it
so relaxin it actually Peaks relatively
early in pregnancy so it doesn't
actually get higher in the later stages
so pregnancy the the hormone is designed
obviously to help us get ready for
childbirth so it softens the ligaments
but on utley around the pelvis is where
it acts and it helps us to open up the
pelvis to deliver a baby so it serves a
very important purpose there's been a
lot of I think talk over the years about
probably owe a lot to do with
overstretching there's a lot of
fear-mongering I think that you know
women need to be really careful with it
stretching and that because relaxing is
in there and everything's really floppy
and you're probably going to do damage
but you know that doesn't bear out it
doesn't bear out the research and
certainly clinically I don't I don't
have hundreds of Yogi's coming in with
you know really damaged joints and
muscles so I don't think from a
stretching perspective that that is such
a big deal in terms of lifting probably
we don't think I don't see that many
issues in terms of joint problems but
what you will find clinically is a lot
of people will self limit what they lift
anyway so if you're talking about your
your power lifters and and people
working at those higher percentages of
1rm we the bigger concerns that we have
regarding that will be the valsalva
which is contraindicated in pregnancy
which we didn't we didn't get to yes
that is important too yeah that's
important to understand so the valsalva
is contraindicated in pregnancy because
it or two reasons really one is because
it creates a spike in blood pressure and
again that could have an effect on the
baby so you gotta remember in pregnancy
we've got around about forty to fifty
percent increase in blood volume the
cardiac output is hugely increase you
know that your your heart and lungs are
working a bloody lot harder when you're
pregnant and actually even in the first
trimester you've got 40% increase in
blood volume so that's why even though
your baby's the size of a peanut you're
like why is this so hard like it's just
exhausting and and I'm trying to run but
I've got I've got no spring in my step
so so there's all these cardiovascular
changes that we need to take into
account so so that's one thing with the
valsalva
and the other thing is that again you
know we talked about intra-abdominal
pressure and pressure on pelvic floor in
pregnancy especially as the pregnancy
progresses you can imagine if you're
doing those really big heavy lifts and
you're creating a lot of intra-abdominal
pressure that pressure is going to go
down into the pelvic floor into or into
the abdominal wall so a lot of women we
we coached over time if they're
experienced lifters we actually do
anticipate that the numbers that they're
lifting or the the volume that they're
lifting is actually going to reduce with
time so when you're talking about the
the joint side of things if you're
coaching people and you're supporting
them and you're you know observing them
and you're also letting them know that
and Molly can talk to the coaching side
of this but the expectation is that
you're probably not even going to be
able to maintain what you've got if
you're an experienced lifter now
interestingly on the topic of less
experienced lifters there actually have
been studies where they've taken
pregnant women and they've put them
through a strength training program in
pregnancy who have never done any kind
of strength training before and they've
had really good effects and they've had
really good results in terms of like
they've actually been able to improve
what they're lifting and this is that
sort of what do you call it the new be
responsive new begins yeah new begins
thank you so pregnant women can have new
be gains as well and what they found is
that there were knowing that there
hadn't shown an increase in
musculoskeletal problems so they're not
finding women who start lifting weights
in pregnancies and obviously these are
like you know I think there were 12 to
15 reps so they're much lower
in terms of the intensity of the weights
that they're lifting but they're not
gonna they're not having knee problems
and back problems and stuff when they're
working within those ranges and that's
something that we know from the research
and there really hasn't been a lot of
research done at the higher higher level
to be honest but I do think that I don't
see it a lot I don't have a lot of you
know lifters coming in with knee
problems and back problems in pregnancy
if they're coached well yeah like Marika
and I had a conversation about that the
other day again the the ethical
considerations of doing research and
pregnant women it's like it's gonna be
difficult to get approved for a study
that's like okay so let's have some of
them lifting around seventy to
seventy-five percent and some of them
lifting around ninety to ninety-five
percent and see what happens guys like
the question is like why you know I mean
like that's like that's potentially
putting mother and baby at risk and like
is it really necessary to to study that
and see what the differences would be so
like Reggie said there's just not a lot
of research up with pregnant women
lifting at those really high intensities
in pregnancy
yeah that's extremely believable one
time an IRB gave me a lot of trouble
because they thought the dose of Crystal
Light that I was giving healthy young
people was just a little bit too high so
I'm sure that ninety ninety-five percent
with pregnant women is gonna be hard to
get by them yeah I can imagine how that
conversation would go like do you think
this is gonna kill any babies I don't
think so
hard to say I mean we haven't that's
what we're trying to investigate if I
knew the answer would I be running the
study alright so know what we've talked
about I'm sorry go ahead Molly well I
was gonna say sweet covered trimester
one things changed a little bit though
in two and three and like I said I'll
kind of give a brief overview and let
Marika fill in any gaps so trimester two
obviously belly's getting a little bit
bigger and I believe I think this was a
recent addition but barbell Olympic
lifting has now been added to the list
of contraindicated activity so there are
things obviously like scuba diving and
skydiving and things like that that are
contraindicated in pregnancy barbell
Olympic lifting has been add to that as
well simply because the as the belly
gets bigger with the path of the bar it
could
you're obviously risk fetal impact
trauma and/or the woman having to change
her techniques such so to avoid her
belly such that it might be dangerous
for her as well so I can't like I said I
can't work that was a recent addition
but I think it I think it was I was
tremors yeah it was pretty recent yeah
belly starts getting bigger um so it
just so that's happening and then
there's also this is generally though
when women see you tend to feel like
best in their pregnancy they tend to
have a little bit more energy for a lot
of them then nausea has subsided and
they you know their belly hasn't gotten
so big that it's starting to really
impede what they're doing in the gym so
trimester 2 is when a lot of women start
to feel more like themselves a couple
things to keep in mind so there are some
folks who recommend pregnant women not
lying on their back after 16 weeks of
pregnancy there have been other people
who recommend that starting at about 28
weeks in pregnancy so the ideas when a
woman is lying on her back that the
pressure of the baby the weight of the
baby is was pressing on her vena cava
reducing blood flow but the interesting
thing is that if a woman is lying on her
back and exercising that blood flow is
only reduced by about 50% and you have
to imagine that women are lying on their
backs oftentimes while they're sleeping
and also if they're on an exam table so
it's one of those tricky things where
some folks say you should absolutely
avoid it starting at 16 weeks some folks
say you know you don't have to start
avoiding it until 28 weeks some folks
say it's not really a big deal as long
as she's not lying on her back she's
only lying on her back for short bouts
but I believe short bouts is not
actually well-defined and then other
folks say it's not a big deal unless she
starts experiencing dizziness fatigue
nausea things like that and so but the
good news is all of those things can be
alleviated if you just elevate her head
by about 15 percent so in general when
it comes to lying on your back during
pregnancy it's Oh probably okay for
short bouts particularly if you're
exercising we I would define short bouts
as probably 30 to 60 seconds so enough
to do a set of glute bridges or
something like that but pay close
attention to the symptoms that you're
having and if you are having symptoms
and/or if you want to be extra safe you
can elevate your head by about 15
percent
upper body by about 15% and then again
later in the second trimester as the
belly starts to grow that's when you
start seeing the abdominal separation or
diastasis recti and again that's
diastasis recti diastasis recti there's
a million different ways to say dr dr a
dram there's all kinds of different
different ways to say we chat we
typically say diastasis recti so you
start to see more of separation of the
abdominal muscles and that is to
accommodate the growing baby and it's
totally normal and there's evidence to
suggest that up to a hundred percent of
women experience some diastasis recti
some separation of the abdominal muscles
in pregnancy it's getting a lot of
attention right now
marika can speak to a little bit more
and how it you know affects pelvic
health or is or isn't correlated to
pelvic health but a lot of women are
yeah feeling really concerned about
they're feeling concerned about how
their stomach looks post pregnancy you
know or and or they're learning that
they have diastasis recti and that might
be affecting the way that their you know
that their stomach looks post pregnancy
and that there's actually something that
they can do about it up to a point so
that's becomes a bigger concern in the
second trimester so we generally around
like late second trimester early third
trimester and again marika can speak to
this there's no definitive research
saying what types of exercises make
diastasis recti worse in pregnancy
however we think it's probably prudent
to avoid exercises that put a ton of
kind of stress on the belly
so like the belly where it's kind of
hanging down like maybe a pushup
position or a plank position and so and
again you don't have to avoid those
altogether you can elevate your hands
slightly to reduce the amount of stress
or pressure that it's putting on the
Linea Alba which is the connective
tissue that starts to thin and separate
and diastasis recti
and then obviously is the weight of the
baby starts you know baby starts growing
weighs more puts more downward pressure
on the pelvic floor just being mindful
of the high impact exercises that you're
doing so if exercises are causing pain
if they're causing leaking or pelvic
floor symptoms if you're feeling
heaviness or dragging if you are feeling
like something's falling out if you are
doing an exercise and you see what's
called like doming or coning so
basically it looks like a like the Linea
Alba the middle of your abdominal wall
is kind of like pressing out or cork
owning more so than just like the
roundness of your belly or yeah other
high impact exercises we generally
reduce or we generally tell most people
that reducing those types of exercises
is going to be beneficial for them later
in their second trimester early through
third trimester awesome and so is such a
good summary yeah I was waiting for
Murray cottage to chime in but it sounds
like she smashed it she's amazing with
the trajectory so one of the things with
the lift with the lifting side of things
is that when you have to bring the bar
past your belly probably there's
probably two concerns with that one is
obviously we talked about the valsalva
and all that kind of stuff with the
heavier styles of lifting but just
there's that concern that you might
basically smash bash your belly on the
way through so there's you know within
the the recommendations we're really
trying to avoid exercises where people
at a high risk of falling or a high risk
of abdominal impact so even things like
I mean I know you guys probably don't do
this in your gyms but box jumps and
things like that we'd probably avoid as
well because you're actually interesting
ly you're three times more likely to
fall in pregnancy and I can say this
from experience too as I had a couple of
massive stacks in my pregnancy and at
some yes it's just something to be aware
of in terms of programming if you're
doing other types of programming it's
just just be aware that their balance
can be a bit off and also that you can
have low blood pressure which means
getting up and down a lot can can
increase dizziness and stuff like that
with the trajectory of the bar then just
sometimes simple things like changing
your changing it like a bar lift to a
couple of kettlebells or a couple of
dumbbells or just or using the the
physical the trap bar though that the
hexagonal kind of one with the what's it
called yeah either either a trap bar X
bar yeah so things like that can be
really can be useful as well for food I
find in pregnancy just in terms of the
positioning just having your hands by
your side can feel more comfortable I
know that doesn't tend to go past the
belly anyway but
it's something that seems to be quite
well tolerated I think you got all the
the main things in terms of the second
trimester Molly and you talked about
heat and all that kind of stuff so yeah
no I think that was a fantastic summary
so are we ready to move on to the third
and final trimester yeah I think so
and like I said I kind of started
covering that a little bit in terms of
second trimester end of second trimester
beginning of third and again in third
trimester depending on you know how
they're feeling how far along they are
they generally tend to start again kind
of feeling more tired the belly's
getting in the way a lot of times
they're feeling maybe it feels like just
getting up and in and out of bed and
ending up the shower or in another car
feels like a little bit of a workout and
so yeah they like as Marika has
mentioned they generally kind of start
to self limit what they're doing a
little bit things might just it might
just feel weird to go hard in pregnancy
to you know to sprint or to lift really
heavy or whatever they're just don't it
just doesn't feel right anymore but I
mean the general principles of strength
and conditioning apply here so I mean
pregnant women can squat they can
deadlift they can press they can pull
they can lunge they can carry they can
do you know all of the same like
principles of strength and conditioning
apply to them they just might be again
dealing with they might be more likely
to be symptomatic experiencing that
pelvic pain heaviness incontinence
leaking symphysis pubis dysfunction
Marika you want to jump in and talk
about that yep so pelvic girdle pain in
pregnancy is really really common
probably go to paint and low back pain
and we kind of group it all together in
many cases because sometimes we can't
tell where it's coming from but
generally with public girdle pain you
either feel it around the front like
around the pubic symphysis and it feels
a bit it feels quite sharp like women
all say it feels like someone's sort of
stabbing them in the groin or they might
feel pain around the sacroiliac joints
and I'll often describe that as a pain
in the butt some women will will will
say to you I've got sciatica but I
actually don't get any pins or needles
or numbness I don't get any pain
radiating much past the buttock so it
seems
to be a little bit more localized than
that so that's you know low back and
pelvic pain really really common in
pregnancy and it's one of those things
that again like we we sort of like blame
everything on relaxin but it's probably
a combination of you know some of the
hormonal changes but you've got all this
extra weight
you've got changes in center of gravity
your muscles that your abdominal wall
has been like stretched around this
growing belly and you can't you actually
physically can't generate as much force
through abdominal wall and they've done
studies in that you're actually you are
weaker in your abdominal wall because
it's obviously in a more length in
position so as all these factors
together which just mean that women are
a bit more susceptible to pain around
the front or the back of the pelvis and
that can limit in terms of exercise so a
lot of your so deadlifts squats where
your feet are parallel you've got two
feet on the ground I don't I actually
find that you can usually get away with
those much more than anything on one leg
or in a split position like split squats
are usually okay and you can if they're
getting pelvic girdle pain if you just
shorten the stance a little bit they'll
usually be fine but things like walking
lunges will often be problematic or
anything like I said anything standing
on one leg or where the forces through
the pelvis are quite different from one
side to the other so for instance if
you're doing a bridge and you tried to
lift one leg that's often problematic or
even sometimes simple things like if
someone's on all fours and they lift one
arm and leg you know like the bird dog
kind of stuff even that can be quite
painful but you can in a gym situation
you can usually modify I find modify
most exercises so that you can keep
people working through their pregnancy
and you know one of the things we I
guess we didn't touch on earlier because
we could probably talk for hours but in
terms of the benefits of exercise in
pregnancy they're really substantial and
all the research supports this there are
so many benefits of exercise in
pregnancy to Mum and to baby and we
really as health and fitness
professionals we want to support women
to continue working out in whatever is
their preferred you know style form for
as long as possible because you know if
they've got a little bit of pain and you
adjust that and keep them working out
and keep them strength training they're
gonna get all the benefits of strength
training but they're also you know in an
environment where they're having fun you
know they're socializing with you guys
and people that they really enjoy
spending time with so there's all the
physical but also the psychological
benefits of exercise and so so I really
cut I guess I encourage people to yes as
a coach if someone has pain modify the
exercise see if you can get them to
reduce the pain so they can continue if
it's persisting always refer on to you
know the health practitioner to make
sure there's nothing more sinister going
on there are some random things in
pregnancy like you can get a transient
osteoporosis in the hip and things like
that where for some reason the baby I
guess starts stealing some calcium out
of mum so anything that it just doesn't
kind of feel right just trust your gut
and always refer on when it comes to
pain but absolutely you know if we want
to keep them exercising for as long as
possible modifications can really work
for pelvic girdle pain ingredients
aren't all so wide stance exercises like
a sumo deadlift or even a squat with a
little bit wider stance women you are
having SPD find that that can aggravate
it's doing things a little bit closer
stance like you said feet a little bit
closer together toes straight ahead is
helpful it's um look I go with trial and
error on that Molly so some people
actually yeah I mean when you go really
really wide yes but I find that sort of
you like your sumo stance for most
people it's actually not that bad I
think it's more that forward backward or
single leg that's worse but you might
actually find with someone that you just
turn their feet outwards you put them
into a little bit of external rotation
and that feels more comfortable so I'd
encourage a little bit of trial and
error a little bit of experimentation
with that and there's no there's no
answer and like you said to encourage
them to keep lifting just you know be
careful not to catastrophize what
they're feeling and help them reno
remind them that they're strong and
resilient and they should let you know
if they're experiencing any symptoms but
there's a lot that you know they can do
in pregnancy and a lot that you can do
to help make sure that they can continue
exercising in pregnancy I mean I am NOT
a I have not been pregnant I'm not a
mother myself but I've worked with a ton
of moms and I know that you know
motherhood is a you know sport that
requires a lot of strength
full-contact sport requires a lot of
strength and so having women you know be
able to like you said spend that time in
pregnancy getting stronger staying
connected with their body they get the
psychological benefits of lifting they
often find a lot of community in lifting
and yeah it's just it's so beneficial
for them and Mariko what does the
research say about exercising during
pregnancy in terms of helping speed up
postpartum recovery I do think there is
some that says that it's an a quicker
recovery certainly better subjective
experience of pregnancy I do think there
is something that extent means that I
have a better person at recovery but I
can't think actually have to talk my
head sorry Molly
no I thought I remembered that as well
and so yeah we can Tomsk in India yeah
we can I mean you can only remember 782
status from you know 1500 studies we
yeah we can jump into the postpartum the
birth and postpartum recovery if you all
want to go there yeah I think this
particular conversation would be
incomplete if we didn't at least address
you know how to manage that period after
birth in terms of training alright so in
terms of childbirth obviously the two
main ways you get a baby out is through
a vaginal delivery or vaginal birth the
midwives will often say Peters get
delivered not babies so I need to sort
of keep stop somebody from saying that
but a vaginal birth or a caesarean
section and as a coach and trainer you
do want to have an understanding of the
kind of birth that they've had we we
have a post natal Park you and I don't
know Molly if you want to like share
that yeah later and just to share it
with your audience if you want to use
that and that's quite comprehensive but
we actually do want to know what kind of
birth I had because it will affect their
return to exercise and how far you're
going to push them so in terms of a
vaginal birth at this sort of most
simplest level you'll have a vaginal
birth where there's no complications
they haven't used any instruments the
Recovery's been straightforward and with
those women they may well find that they
recover relatively quickly and
what I will say about postnatal recovery
and it's really tricky to give timelines
and I'm very very careful with my
clients not to say oh you should be back
to doing X Y & Z by three months or six
months or a year I keep it really really
vague and the reason for that is like
you know I've run exercise classes for a
long time with with postnatal women and
the recovery is so variable and I do
think as a whole like the women who are
stronger and fitter before they come
into pregnancy they do tend to like in
my experience they do tend to do better
postnatally and whether that is that
they've got some more baseline strength
or whether they've just got better
like neuromuscular you know yeah you
know whatever connections and things
like that who knows but they do sense
they do tend to recover a bit quicker
but you know we often say it takes nine
months to make a baby and it takes about
nine to twelve months to recover so you
know when it comes to a vaginal birth
you might well find that someone at six
weeks if they're recovering fine they're
back in the gym they're doing some light
weights they're doing some training
they're back to running maybe four
months increasing load through lifting
but you know it really does take months
rather than weeks to recover in terms of
that birth screening though probably
some of the things that are going to
flag up for us as being more of a high
risk would be someone who has had a
perineal tear so for you fellas I don't
know if your your dad's but the perineal
tear is is when there is during the
during the delivery during the birth
there is a tear from the vagina towards
the anus and that is in that pushing
stage of labor stage sorry term you can
get grade 1 or grade 2 tear is quite
superficial they'll stitch that up many
women will do fine with that when you
start going into a grade 3 or 4 tears so
if someone writes great three or four
tear on their screening form I would
encourage a follow-up question of okay
you're seeing the public health physio
is this something that you have any
concerns about once you get to a 3 or 4
tear it involves the back passage
basically so the anal sphincter and so
we do worry about fecal incontinence and
really those women should be having
follow-up care and I would encourage
them to do that
from the arm and then from in terms of
the other thing in the vaginal
deliveries there you go I said again
paternal birth is with forceps
so forceps which I think all the big
solid servers if you've ever seen them
that's kind of what they look like so
it's when they put the big solid servers
in to help help bring out the baby
the problem with forceps is that they do
a lot of damage to the pelvic floor if
someone has had a forceps delivery that
is again a higher risk in terms of
public floor dysfunction and it's
something like I want to say three or
four times the risk of prolapse it's
really high so if someone's had a
forceps delivery and they've ticked that
in the little box that would be another
person just to have that follow-up
follow-up question you know are you
under the care of a public health physio
we recommend that you just make sure
that you get things checked out because
you know if you want to get back to
lifting you know your three RS three
area 1rm you know we really want to make
sure that you're safe to do that so they
would be the high-risk from that
perspective now we talk about a
c-section so c-section or obviously is
abdominal wall surgery and I think
sometimes it's a little bit dismissed in
a way as being I don't know the easy way
out or it's easy to recover from or you
know all sorts of stuff but ultimately
it is major abdominal surgery and people
do need time to recover from that if you
look at the research in terms of how
strong that scar is because I don't know
whether whether you guys have the
mindset which is what I had before I did
a lot of pre and postnatal training was
that I you know after six weeks things
are pretty well healed just crack on and
you know gradually increase you know as
as you feel comfortable and that that
tended to be the advice and after
c-section
you know after six weeks scars pretty
well healed off you go but actually the
the strength of that abdominal fashio is
only about fifty to sixty percent at six
weeks and even by six or seven months
you're about 70 to 90 percent so it does
take quite a long time to build up that
strength of the abdominal wall again so
it's just keeping in mind I guess the
the concepts of tissue healing because I
think when it comes to postnatal
recovery I often say to my clients look
it's a bit like having an ACL
reconstruction right so we don't
say to people okay you've had you've had
surgery to your knee give it six weeks
rest and then just gradually go back to
doing the things that you want to do we
don't we don't we look at range of
motion we look at strength we look at
function we loaded up we really build on
that strength can we build at the power
and we work on the sports specific
drills and that's how I see the
postpartum recovery and that's something
that we teach your girl's gone strong as
well as to get that foundation stuff
early but then thinking like what is
that person's goals and how can I get
them there and knowing that it could
take months rather than weeks and work
through the stages and tick those boxes
in terms of what they need to do rather
than we do this for six weeks and then
we do this for six weeks if that mean
does that make sense yeah I am as we
were working on our pre and postnatal
coaching certification my partner Casey
actually had a full rupture of his
patellar tendon and had to have surgery
and you know had this very very specific
and intentional protocol like physical
therapy protocol and recovery and just
slow return to activity and movement and
it was at the time that we were working
on the certification and I was hearing
stories from women who literally have to
beg their doctor for a referral to a
physical therapist post c-section and it
was so infuriating to me that there was
such a such an obvious and clear and
well-defined and intentional protocol to
help you know someone who who ruptured
their patellar tendon to return to
activity but women have a c-section have
major abdominal surgery are then caring
for an infant often alone you know if
they're they might be lucky if their
partner gets two weeks of paternity
leave and then people ask him why he's
taking so long off work to help her with
the baby she's having major abdominal
surgery and there's no you know no
automatic referral to a pelvic health
physical therapist that depends on where
you live based in the u.s. obviously so
there's not an automatic referral here
and many women tell me that they have to
fight with their doctor to get a
referral to pelvic health physical
therapy post delivery and two other
really that are related really big myths
about returning to exercise post
pregnancy similar to what marika said
number one
that you can't do anything for six weeks
and number two is that at six weeks
you're automatically good to go back to
whatever you want so in the first six
weeks and again Marika as Marika said
the women's recoveries are going to be
so variable depending on the type of
birth that they had and again what they
were doing prior to delivery how they're
feeling what kind of support they have
at home you know what's going on with
their baby is their baby sleeping at all
are they breastfeeding are they not you
know what other stuff is going on are
they having postpartum depression so
they have you know postpartum PTSD just
based on what's going on and again
giving hard-and-fast guidelines is not
particularly useful and also giving
people no direction is not very useful
so at ggs we typically break down the
postpartum recovery into three phases
and so the first six weeks ish which and
again it's it's six weeks of time but
that might start for women at two weeks
post delivery or three weeks post
delivery for weeks the first six weeks
are the rehab and recovery phase a week
7 to 18 are going to be returning to
exercise and then weeks 18 to 42 is what
we call bulletproof your body and the 0
to 6 weeks the first few weeks literally
just starts off with some gentle
breathing exercises and in that first
and after about two weeks of just doing
gentle breathing exercises we add in
some gentle body weight movements and
they really important key here is that
these should be no more strenuous than
the activities of daily living so you
know we tell women not to do anything
for six weeks but they're squatting up
and down off the toilet they are
carrying their baby if they have other
children who weigh twenty thirty forty
pounds they're probably picking them up
and holding them there you know bending
over and getting stuff out of the
dishwasher whatever they're doing all
these household tasks right with that
you know we're telling them they can't
they can't do you know exercise like
like bending over getting something like
out of the dishwasher picking up your
forty pound child like doing a glute
bridge on the ground with a lot of
intention and this be a specific
breathing exercise is probably going to
be less quote-unquote dangerous than
bending over and picking up your forty
pound child after you you know have a
c-section two or three weeks ago so it's
like um kind of reminds me of when we
say like strength trainings dangerous
for kids and then you throw
like into like you know field sports or
whatever where they're doing all kinds
of activity and a completely
uncontrolled environment and we're
expecting them to be able to do that
with no like formal strength training or
like solid you know controlled
environment experience in the gym so
it's kind of like that so we generally
within the first two weeks a lot of
breathing exercises rest maybe some
light walking ten minutes at a time
something like that but making sure that
they're really prioritizing rest the
next three to four weeks you know maybe
some like glute bridges clamshells wall
slides maybe some like bodyweight squats
or bodyweight box squats but again very
gentle only if they feel up to it and
making sure that they are spending
plenty of time resting but for a lot of
women it's gonna feel good to kind of
get up and move their body around a
little bit and then in the seven to
eighteen week period if they're feeling
okay that's when we gently start
incorporating them back into exercise so
maybe again doing some more you know
bodyweight squats or very lightly loaded
squats and step ups you know light
inverted rows band pull apart just again
the gentle just very progressively
return and slowly and progressively
returning them back to exercise around
week 18 which Marika was hanging around
like a month for you can often start
bumping up the intensity a little bit
they can slowly maybe start returning to
a little bit heavier lifting but now you
know wouldn't go too extreme maybe start
walk jogging a little bit depending on
what their recovery is like and then
from that week eighteen or nineteen to
forty two is when again they keep
progressing back to exercise maybe
they're getting back into the barbell
squats track bar deadlifts you know
bench press things like that and then
the goal for the training programs and
the kind of programming that we provide
is that after somewhere between week
forty two and fifty-two which is again
about 10 to 12 months at that point they
are prepared to return to whatever
activity they love and again that's
going to be variable based on them their
birth their experiences the support they
have at home what they were training
like prior to pregnancy but that's kind
of our general timeline so six about six
weeks of just straight rehab and
recovery gentle body weight movements
breathing a little bit of walking about
12 weeks of gently returning to exercise
slowly and progressively and then about
another 24 weeks of building back up
into some of the more intense lifting
but still being really mindful of
symptoms and progressing slowly and then
somewhere around 10 to 12 months they
should be able to return to whatever
activities more strenuous activities
they love awesome so we're already you
know we're all you know 10 12 months
postnatal at this point and I did see a
YouTube video I believe it was by marika
and I think the title said once
postnatal always postnatal so now that
we're talking to what you know 10 12
months postnatal look what does that
quote mean I think it's I don't even
remember how old is that video the
research department goes very deep into
the archives I I'm not very I'm not very
good on youtube I don't have a lot of
content so well done and finding
something so one person I don't always
post now I guess is something that we
hear a lot of from a lot of public
health videos and I the reality is is
that after pregnancy and childbirth for
most women their body is not the same
and I think that's something that we try
and acknowledge in that for instance if
you have a vaginal birth your pelvic
floor muscles will stretch sort of three
and a half times that length your
abdominal wall if you've been pregnant
whether you've had a c-section or
vaginal birth your abdominal wall does
get stretched and for most people this
this it's a slight difference afterwards
it's not necessarily huge but we are we
do see you know the consequences of
child of pregnancy and childbirth you
know four to eight years down the track
for a lot of women will start developing
some public floor dysfunction and that
could be related to age it could be I
think sometimes I do wonder whether just
as a you know like you get out of this
toddler zone right you send your
children off to daycare or off - you
know pre-primary or whatever you call it
in America and then you suddenly as a
mum go sweet I've got some time to
myself I'm gonna go do some boot camp if
I haven't been through that process that
Molly talked about you're still at risk
of pelvic floor dysfunction whether that
is for
we use down the track or ten years down
the track so I think you know we just
like to sort of acknowledge the fact
that you know pregnancy and childbirth
does change your body in in and in many
ways it it recovers beautifully but
there can be some lingering issues on a
longer term basis and I think it's it's
really good to address that early on but
if not if it's five years down the track
and you start having issues there's no
problem with starting some rehab at that
point too but I think we just want to
keep the conversation open that it's not
that well you're one year down the track
everything is fine you're never going to
have any problems your body is
completely back to normal cuz I think
that's a bit of a fallacy yeah I was
gonna say there's some nuance here and I
know this is going to surprise you Eric
and Greg but people on the internet like
things to be black and white and they
are not comfortable with with saying
like well it depends right so when we
say once postnatal always postnatal or
once postpartum always postpartum people
a lot of people find themselves very
really upset by that because they think
that the idea is that means that women
are fragile and once they've had
children that there's something wrong
with their bodies their fragile their
broken they can't have a return to
activities they love and that's just not
true it is simply an acknowledgment that
their body has been through unique
anatomical and physiological changes
that health and fitness professionals
need to understand and need to
understand you know what considerations
what symptoms what consequences might
might arise from that and so it's not to
say that they can't they can't be strong
and resilient and powerful and even
stronger than they were prior to
pregnancy and return to activities they
love and live you know an amazing active
life it simply means that they've been
through their body spent through these
experiences and that can't be ignored
and that again like marika said those
symptoms might show up later
down the line when when there's you know
an inciting factor like pregnancy like
delivery like menopause a lot of women
start to find that they have pelvic
health considerations because there's
hormonal changes they're experiencing
you know some vaginal atrophy or you
know whatever they're they're you know
possibly losing muscle mass as well and
bone mass and things like that and so
they might not they they might have some
pelvic floor symptoms during an hour
after menopause that their childbirth or
pregnancy and childbirth contributed to
but they just didn't show up until later
on down the line because basically the
straw hadn't broken the camel's back yet
so yes once once postnatal or once
postpartum always postpartum simply
means they then through those
experiences you can't undo it you know
people like talking about getting your
body back you you don't ever go back to
your quote-unquote pre-baby body because
you have had a baby your baby or your
baby your body is post baby that doesn't
mean it's not a good body a strong body
a healthy body and active body it just
means that it's different and so I yeah
I think providing that nuance and
context for people is really important
so that they don't think that we're
saying postpartum women are fragile but
that they also understand that there may
be considerations and things that think
that they need to understand as a health
and fitness professional awesome that
makes a lot of sense in this hour and a
half so far we've covered a lot of
ground and I do want to be respectful of
your time so we are gonna wrap up pretty
soon here but you know we kind of talked
early on about how for Greg and I were
kind of exploring some blind spots with
this conversation and so I know I've
learned a lot in the last hour and a
half I'm sure many of our listeners have
as well one of the final questions I
want to ask obviously we don't have a
lot of time to get into details but to
fuel our future googling what are some
other blind spots that that a lot of
male coaches out there should know about
what you'll be we be looking into in
terms of some of these blind spots that
we we might not even be aware that we
have when it comes to working with
female clients unknown unknowns to use
Donald Rumsfeld's turn a phrase we
touched a little bit at the very start
on pelvic pain and I think public pain
is is something that it's a little bit
of a tricky one in terms of a coaching
sense but the more and more I kind of
look into this as a physiotherapists you
know people with groin pain or back pain
pelvic girdle pain abdominal pain some
of this can be do some of this can be
due to pelvic floor overactivity so I
think in terms of
avec Fleur we often come from a mindset
that the public floors always weak
especially after childbirth and we need
to strengthen and strengthen and I know
I've had a lot of clients who have gone
to for instance a post natal Pilates you
know program and they've done so much
public floor strengthening and have
actually got developed quite a lot of
pain or if they had pain it's gotten
worse so I just wanted to mention that
the pelvic floor can actually be
overactive and that's relatively common
especially in athletes and the way that
that might present and I don't you know
the sex sexual pain is probably one of
the most common ones and that's probably
not something that you're going to
discuss with your clients when they're
deadlifting you know do you have pain
with intercourse but it is on our
screening form and payment intercourse
is something that is really quite common
and that's something as Public Health
physio as we deal a lot with but pelvic
floor of activity can also mean that
people have difficulty emptying their
bladder and bowel so they find it's hard
to pee or it's hard to poo and then we
teach them how to actually learn to
relax their pelvic floor and the other
thing is that they yeah they can just
develop pain in and around the pelvis
and abdominal wall so I just wanted to
mention that because just to put it in
in the back of your mind because it
might come up at some point that this is
something that that can show up and
certainly really common in athletes and
groin pain and the pelvic floor has a
lot of links to the to the muscles
around the hip so obturator internus
prime example hip rotator part of the
pelvic floor so you can have an
overactive public floor on one side that
actually presents as hip pain so that's
just one example but I just wanted to
mention that because I think that's
something that a lot of people are not
aware of and always thinking like we
have to strengthen strengthen strengthen
the pelvic floor but one of the things
that we we really look at is does this
pelvic floor elevate so it does the
public floor lifts and does the public
floor relax okay and we want to make
sure that we have full range of motion
of the pelvic floor that it's not stuck
in that on position which would be like
you walking around with your biceps just
switched on all the time there is a
there is obviously there's a like a a
baseline level of activity of the pelvic
floor but for some people it's way too
high
okay.you moment all right well I feel
like we've done a pretty thorough job of
discussing you know a lot of strength
training related pre and postnatal
related topics and you know at girls
come strong we specialize in covering
women's specific health fitness and
nutrition topics in it I think you know
one of the big myths I've briefly
touched on this is that training you
know that women are a niche training
women are niche but in our experience
around 67 to 75 percent of people who
hire a coach or trainer or women and
women deserve to work with coaches who
understand them they deserve to have
coaches who understand that their
experiences might be different you know
we know a lot of huge topics that we
cover at girls got stronger the body
image struggles that women have so
eighty percent of women in Canada and 81
percent of women in the u.s. reported
being dissatisfied with their body
seventy-nine percent of young girls
ten-year-old girls are herbs are 80
percent of ten year-old girls are afraid
of being fat 79 percent of young girls
report opting out of important life
events because they don't like the way
that they look and eighty-five percent
of women report opting out of important
life events weddings reunions being in
pictures with their kids things like
that because they don't like the way
their body looks every scent study and I
think it was 2014 from the University of
South Carolina surveyed over 4,000 women
seventy-five percent of them reported
engaging in some form of disordered
eating disordered eating is the highest
predictor of developing an eating
disorder eating disorders are the most
deadly of all mental illnesses there's
obviously all the pre and postnatal
stuff that we've talked about on here
today there are considerations for
working with women around their
menstrual cycle it's a really big topic
do you need to change a woman's
nutrition training around her menstrual
cycle long story short is the research
does not support blanket recommendations
how all women should change their
nutrition and exercise across their
cycle the same way however certainly
women were actually working on a big
article about this if girls come strong
what the research says and then also
serving our community and getting
gathered a lot of anecdotal evidence and
experiences from them about ways that
they
modify their nutrition and exercise
based on their based on their cycle but
there's considerations there 10% of
women have endometriosis which means
often again really painful periods which
can lead to pelvic floor dysfunction
there's you know menopause related
issues that women experience so I just
think it's important for health and
fitness professionals to realize that
understanding how to work with women is
not a niche women deserve coaches who
understand them and there's very little
evidence based interdisciplinary
comprehensive information about working
with women available and that's why
we're really excited and proud about the
stuff that we do at GG s and we're
thankful to folks like you who give us a
you know a platform to share it with
your community because I do think this
is going to be an eye-opening yeah an
eye-opening conversation for a lot of
health and fitness professionals to hear
but yeah I would say things are on body
image things around disordered eating
things around women's experiences I mean
81 percent of them in the u.s. report
experiencing street harassment that
numbers as high as 99 percent other
places one-third of women and globally
will be sexually assaulted in their
lifetime there's just a lot of
experiences that women have that are not
saying that men never have them it's
just on average women are more likely to
have them than men that affect the way
that they feel about themselves the way
they feel about their bodies the way
certain environments affect them like
really aggressive gym environments so
yeah I just think there's a lot of of
those types of topics that Health
Affairs professionals if they're
interested in truly understanding their
clients and being able to provide a safe
supportive environment in which their
clients feel heard and understood
there's those topics would be great ones
to tackle yeah and you guys do really
really important work with with girls
gone strong for everyone listening be
sure to check the the show notes for
this episode we're gonna provide links
if you'd like to stay up to date with
girls gone strong stay up-to-date with
Molly and Marika and everything that
they're working on this has been a
really really informative conversation
we are super thankful for your
time we really appreciate you taking the
time to to teach us so much tonight I've
definitely learned way more from this
interview than I have any of the other
interviews we've done yeah I agree with
that for sure so thank you both so much
for for teaching us tonight well thank
you for having us
I'm so happy and proud of so much
respect for you all and what you do I
think I've told you all I'm a subscriber
to mass I love you I love your else work
I love what you do I appreciate you all
giving us the opportunity to share this
stuff with your community and yeah I'm
just proud to be in the industry with
people like you all and I just want to
say it yeah I'll just back that up
really really so excited to being able
to do this talk with you guys and share
the things that we get really excited
talking about and to have this platform
because I'm sure it'll be really useful
for many people and also just to say
thanks to both of you I actually am on
the mailing list too for math and I have
the art and science of lifting books and
I just think the amount of I can
appreciate the amount of time and energy
that you put into all your research and
your articles and there's so much that
goes on behind the scenes that takes a
lot of time and energy and I just want
to say on behalf of all of us thank you
for all the hard work that you do
because I think it's fantastic it is our
pleasure would you have any interest in
plugging any of your own products and
not just ours
well yeah our pre and postnatal coaching
certification it is the literally I am
being a hundred percent like this is not
a hyperbolic literally the world's first
and only certification pre and post a
notification that is comprehensive in
terms of covering coaching psychology
female anatomy and physiology nutrition
exercise rest recovery programming the
birth process all specific to pre and
postnatal women it's evidence-based so
there's over 300 references in there
it's interdisciplinary 16 experts six
pelvic health physios for PhDs in
exercise science molecular biology
psychology and behavior change for pre
and postnatal experts ob/gyn doula
Midwife nurse practitioner all of those
people worked on the certification
so it's comprehensive evidence-based
interdisciplinary it comes to the 500
page textbook so if this type of stuff
interests you and you want to have I
mean there's great information about
working with pre and postnatal women
that exists all over the internet if you
don't want to have to vet it all
yourself if you don't want to have to
pull bits and pieces together and try to
make sense of the context if you want
you know transformative information that
actually tells you how to work with pre
and postnatal women that certification
would be would be your best bet and if
you go to girls gun strong calm /c PPC
that stands for certified pre and
postnatal coach you can learn more about
it or you can just google pre and post
natal coaching certification girls come
strong yeah so that would be that would
be awesome
marika is gonna say in terms of our
Facebook group to the coaching and
training women women group it's um a
really lovely space for people to ask
questions and share experiences so if
any of the coaches want to join that
that's that's a free Facebook group that
how many people are not 30,000 32,000
yeah a health and fitness professionals
or it's called ggs coaching and training
women it's totally free
folks awesome folks like Marika and
other experts who work on our
certifications are in that group
answering questions it's just a really
supportive group it's guys were like I
don't know if I'm supposed to be in here
it's like yes we want you in there
lately yeah we want you asking questions
I'd say it's probably 25% men and they
are about 75% women but it's a great
space where you can get access to our
experts and our community members and
moderators it's just a really really
cool uplifting group where we talk about
a lot of this type of information and if
I can plug a podcast on another podcast
I don't know if that's poor etiquette
I'll do it uh-huh go for it was that a
grumble my colleague Antony lo and I we
have a podcast called the women's health
podcast it's obviously very different
from the stronger than science but it's
it's really about issues related to
women's health so if people have an
interest in women's health we interview
people around the globe just about
things like public health but yeah
anything to do with women's health
really so that's a special interest feel
free to come and listen to us we're
nowhere near as professional and I don't
have the radio voice the radio voice
that
Eric has boss we have a lot of fun so
it's kind it's kind of interesting
alright so if you're listening and
you're like me and found out throughout
the course of this podcast that you have
about 200 more blind spots than you knew
about there are plenty of resources out
there to just get to work and start to
start learning more about some of these
topics so once more we'd like to thank
Molly and Marika for joining us we'd
like to thank everyone for listening and
we will see you on another episode of
the stronger by science podcast thanks
for listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another healthcare professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it visit stronger by science
comm to check out the products and
services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you